on the banks of the river seven sits the
empty shell of barkley nuclear power
station it was decommissioned in 1989
and by the end of this decade all but
one of the uk's remaining nuclear sites
will also be shut down
that power gap and the fact our energy
security is currently in the spotlight
is why nuclear power will play a big
part in the government's new energy
strategy we've seen what happens when
somebody like putin gets hold of that
energy supply so next week in the in the
energy strategy we'll be looking for a
greater mix of different ways to produce
our energy
which do not rely on imported
hydrocarbons as gas and oil and side of
things particularly from
russia the government says its strategy
will include an increase in offshore
wind solar and hydrogen energy
onshore wind farms have been played down
with number 10 saying they will always
be subject to consent from local
authorities
when it comes to nuclear the business
secretary kwazii kwatang has hinted up
to seven new sites could be in operation
by 2050
that is ambitious the only new nuclear
power plant currently under construction
is hinckley point c in somerset
the problem with huge projects like this
is that they take years to complete and
actually generate electricity they can
run wildly over schedule and well over
budget it's why small nuclear reactors
smrs which are quicker to create may
form part of the government's plan
government advisers on energy say
large-scale nuclear will be needed
we've seen um demonstrated over and over
again in countries from sweden and
france to korea and japan
that if you make a
intention to develop a programmatic
approach to delivering multiple plants
you can achieve a level of cost
reduction that could enable nuclear
energy to be really competitive and
delivered at a much faster rate whatever
the nuclear option it doesn't provide an
immediate solution to the current
squeeze on household budgets the
government hasn't done enough there's no
way they can say they've done enough the
scheme they put forward i think where
the chances offering to lend us our own
money and pay it back over five years is
completely unrealistic and doesn't meet
the scale of the challenge just how our
energy is produced and where it comes
from are tricky areas for the government
with spiraling costs families will be
keen for an energy plan
that helps them financially as well
dan white is sky news
in somerset